let's talk to one of those republican
senators we've got josh hawley of
missouri joining us now from washington
senator hawley good morning to you
i want to get into a policy matter the
direct payments that you're pushing for
but before that
let's touch on two matters of politics
first mitch mcconnell most senior uh
republican in the senate
now congratulating president-elect biden
and kamala harris
do you join him in that congratulations
you know tony i'm not there yet i think
this process will end on january the 6th
which is when congress has to certify
the results of the electoral college
obviously the electoral college is very
significant
their vote very significant earlier but
the certification happens on january the
6th and
until then i think president trump
certainly has every right to
pursue the legal remedies he wants to
pursue and to be heard but
january 6th i think is the key date the
the legal runway is very short at this
point
january 6 is typically a formality
congress tabulates the votes to come in
from the states
mitch mcconnell is reportedly asking
senators like yourself
not to object to that formal count are
you considering objecting in the senate
well i'm studying what's been done in
the past tony and after the 2004
election and 2016
democrats raised concerns both in the
house and the senate this is really the
only forum that the constitution of the
laws give to
senators and to congress people the
opportunity to raise concerns about the
election so i'm reading what's been done
in the past
we've got a hearing today in the united
states senate on the election
uh so we'll see so you're well this
could come to a full vote then
both houses of congress on january 6
very interesting
in the meantime though many americans
are in need and there's a big discussion
on capitol hill about how to get them
relief
you and senator bernie sanders are
working together to push
the idea of direct payments checks
twelve hundred dollars
for individuals five hundred dollars for
children is that part of the latest bill
that was discussed last night among
leaders
i don't know the answer that yet tony
but i certainly hope it is because the
most
important thing that congress can do now
is to get assistance into the hands of
working families and working people
these are the folks who should be first
in line for coveted relief not last
they shouldn't be an afterthought
working people have borne the brunt of
this pandemic
and they need direct support and i'm
willing to do everything i can
everything in my power to make sure that
they get it
so the pushback from members of your own
party as well as democrats
is that the current bill the 748
billion dollar bill already includes
targeted payments relief for rent for
hunger
for joblessness and what you're talking
about is expensive and goes to everybody
as opposed to just the particular people
in need what's your response to that
well first of all working people are in
need and when you see the the people the
lines of folks lining up for food
support
uh trying to get help paying their rent
making their car payments i just talked
to a young mother in st louis with two
boys who said that she can either keep
making her car payments
uh or else she can do something for her
kids for christmas she can't do she
can't do all of it and this is this is
this story is being repeated over and
over
and over the need for food for instance
is through the roof in my state demand
for food up 50
in food banks here's the point tony
working people are in need
we're not talking about giving checks to
everybody for heaven's sakes we're
talking about working families we're
talking about those who have borne the
brunt of the pandemic and the quickest
way
to get them help and relief is to get
them direct support is to give them a
check like we did in march
so then here's the key question on the
principle that something is better than
nothing
are you willing to support because we
need everybody's support there in
congress for us to go forward
are you willing to support the 748
billion dollar bill they provide some
relief
if it doesn't include the checks that
you're talking about no i've made very
clear that unless there is direct
support for working americans i'm not
going to support covert relief why would
the government tony give hundreds of
billions of dollars
to big business or to government or to
other entities and not
give it to working families who need it
the most that makes
no sense whatsoever we need to target it
to the people who need it
the most and that's working families
quickly if you could center because we
have to go so you're prepared to hold
congress back from their holiday break
unless you get this direct vote on
payments every option is on the table
tony the working people of this country
need somebody to stand up and say they
need relief and that's what i'm going to
do
all right as you've said it's going to
be an interesting week senator hawley
thank you very much
thank you